Stella astronomy so the work with stars
has actually a strong tradition of of
women working in the field and making
significant contributions many people
certainly about a hundred years ago they
just thought our stories are not so
interesting let's study galaxies that
was the big thing because that was the
time and when people found out that
universe is expanding and that was of
course found out by studying galaxies so
that was a hot topic women were hired to
do stellar work so Stella in both ways
working with stars but it also actually
turned out that their work was Stella
because they did so much they classified
stars they're calculated positions and
and other things about about all these
objects for example Annie jump cannon
classified in her lifetime I think half
a million stars or something and her
classification scheme is still used and
still taught I I teach it in my
introductory astronomy class and another
lady Cecilia Payne Capuchin she found
out that stars are made mostly from
hydrogen and helium stars are made
seventy-five percent hydrogen 25 percent
helium but at that time that was maybe
around 1914 1915 it was thought that
stars are made of the same material as
the earth and so this was absolutely
brilliant because she applied quantum
mechanical knowledge to stars for the
very first time and at first people
laughed at it and they wouldn't believe
her but this is such a fundamental
result I cannot stress this enough I
mean everything we know about the
universe rests now on the assumption and
the knowledge that what stars are made
of namely mostly hydrogen helium because
the universe is mostly made of hydrogen
and helium and so these are just two
examples of these early works
by these women who were called the
computers the Harvard computers because
they all worked up there and and they
painstakingly did all these these
classifications and calculations that
today indeed computers do but without
their contributions
I think our overall knowledge of
astronomy would not or for a long time
would not have been what it was